hello everyone and welcome to an
outstanding game from round seven of
this year's singfield cup it is Fabiano
corana versus Wesley so and this game
really shows how even U even if two such
incredible top elite players like Fabian
Wesley meet and they play a top engine
moves and they play a line that has been
played many many times before and even
one player manages to surprise the other
player the other player will still uh
play top top engine moves and absolutely
crush the other player uh it's a 25 move
miniature you guys love this especially
if you play the nimzo or if you love
playing against the nimzo so let's dive
straight into it and then we are going
to discuss how this and if it affects
the the standings and the well chances
of qualifying for the next Fay
candidates tournament not for Fabby but
basically now it's between Wesley and
lener Dominguez Perez and maybe some
others if they if they manage to to uh
play better so let's dive straight into
it Fabiano corana has the wide pieces
and he opens with PA on to D4 we have
Knight to F6 C4 E6 and as advertised the
nimzo Indian defense Knight to C3 and
Bishop to B4 uh we have E3 Queen to C2
and E3 are the main lines and um elite
players will usually go for one of the
two very rarely will they go for some
sort of a sideline like you will see it
if maybe I don't know Jordan loves to
play I've seen him play a lot of A3 but
um yeah Queen to C and E3 for classical
chess I believe is what the top players
go for so E3 and pawn to C E5 Wesley
also goes for the main move Bishop to D3
is the main move here Knight to E2 by
Fabby we have Pawn to D5 and now Pawn to
A3 asking the always unpleasant question
what do you do with the bishop do you
capture or do you go back Wesley goes
back and now D captures on C5 we have D
captures and C4 and Bishop to D2 again
all been played before Knight beat to D7
and now Knight to G3 preparing to
develop the bishop you want to capture
on C4 Castle King side and the game
continues and usually how this will play
out out as it has been reached before
his Knight captures on C5 where black
gets access to B3 and D3 but of course
white captures on C4 uh B4 now becomes a
threat black will go back and now both
players will castle and then maybe
something like B4 and then the Knight
moves and the game continues uh all all
been seen before but Wesley goes for
Pawn to B6 he doesn't capture on C5 he
actually offers a pawn and maybe even
more and the point is that if you
capture here Wesley wants to play Bishop
to A6 and now let's say you capture her
captures on A7 okay white is up material
but these two Bishops will be incredibly
unpleasant now the pawn is defended you
don't have Bishop captures on C4 you
have to develop via D2 square and then
the Knight will get access to B3 and D3
Square so maybe not something you want
to allow uh but after this B6 move Fabby
plays Queen to F3 he goes after The Rook
here and it is the top engine reputation
of uh Pawn to B6 maybe reputation is a
bit of a strong word as this is all
still within within dsh Terr
but you have to know exactly what you
are doing and now it seems like Bishop
to A6 is a great move because now the
queen defends the rook and also the
bishop defends the pawn here but now
Pawn to B4 is incredibly strong as it
traps the bishop on A5 and C captures on
B3 outan is not possible due to Bishop
captures on A6 as the bishop on A6 is
undefended so after Queen to F3 Rook to
B8 by Wesley and now Pawn to C6 Fabby
creates a pass Pawn here Knight to E5
attacks the queen and also gets ready to
to pick up the pawn on C6 Queen to F4
and now well you could go for Knight
captures and then give up the the C4
Pawn uh Wesley goes for Bishop captures
on C3 first and it seems that this move
is asking a bit too much from the
position because now Fabby plays Bishop
captures on C3 is threatening to win the
Knight here Knight captures on C6 but
now Fabby doesn't capture on C4 he goes
Rook to D1 puts pressure on the queen uh
his Queen all already guards the C7
Square so you can't go there you have to
go to E7 or play this weird looking
Bishop D7 move but that's um not really
not really something you want to do so
Queen to E7 and now Bishop captures and
C4 it seems like Wesley's position is
perfectly fine okay the The Rook is
looking a little bit weird here because
uh it's attacked by the queen and the
Knight defends it uh but if he can
Castle should be great can he Castle no
he can because if he castles what's
Fab's idea here I'm sure you guys see it
without even pausing the video uh of
course The Rook is only defended by the
Knight so the the idea is Bishop to B5
there's no defense against this point
being that after let's say Bishop to B7
now okay the Rooks are connected and
defending each other you simply capture
here and play Bishop B4 you skewer the
queen and that's all there is to it so
uh if you can't Castle you have to
figure out how to continue this and
prepare castling so what can you do here
well Wesley said all right Pawn to B5
let's get rid of this bishop and uh now
Bishop to B5 will not be even an option
but Fabby plays Bishop captures on F6
attacks the queen and now problem is if
you play G captures which already looks
very ugly there's this Knight to E4 move
going after D6 check and Knight captures
an F6 check and there's just no good
move here to give you a short example if
you capture the bishop Knight captures
with check the king uh cannot go to the
D file have to go to F6 and now this
will be just mate in one and that's all
there is so after Bishop captures an F6
Wesley has to recapture with the queen
so Queen captures on F6 was played and
now Faby plays Queen to D6 not allowing
castles while attacking the Knight on C6
and what can Wesley do here well uh not
not much capturing the bishop here is uh
not all that impressive because Queen
captures on C6 and now well you're never
castling you're not um you're not going
to survive this and uh well there's just
not all that much you can't go here if
you go here then Queen to D6 check will
win the Rook uh dead lost so Wesley
finds a way to continue he plays Pawn to
E5 now okay the Knight is defended the
queen uh is being offered as a trade uh
but Fab is now completely winning it's
only move 17 but Fabby already has a
knockout blow so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Fabby and
help him reach 2800 once again while I
give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
looking for Waste harass your opponent's
king and deny him castling privileges
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Bishop captures on
F7 yes we will even do it in slow motion
because it's very nice uh and now if
Queen captures then again you have Queen
captures with check and your position is
dead lost and if you capture with the
King what Wesley did now comes uh Queen
to C7 with check and now how do you play
this you don't uh uh you you don't have
Knight E7 because the Rook hangs you
can't play Queen to E7 because the
Knight hangs if you go King to G6 which
is possible then Rook to D6 uh sort of
the queen hangs but even if you block
with Bishop to E6 just Queen captures
here and uh yeah there's no no surviving
this you can defend here but then white
will just Castle play F4 and uh uh it's
just it's just pure pure torture so
after Queen to C7 Wesley said all right
I'm going to give back material Queen to
E7 now you have to capture the Knight
Fabi did capture it and Wesley played
Bishop to B7 so is Wesley back in the
game if he can get the rook and maybe
play King to G8 his position will still
be playable uh although still very much
lost but Fabby just plays Queen captures
on B5 he even allows Bishop captures on
G2 because it really doesn't matter
Bishop Capt on G2 was played now Queen
to C4 with check and you don't even have
Queen to E6 because of Rook to D7 check
now you have to play King F6 to to guard
the queen on E6 and if King to F6 then
comes Knight to H5 with check and that's
it now you either lose the queen or you
go to F5 and the Knight captures on G7
with a fork and black gets very quickly
checkmated it's even going to be a very
nice checkmate where after the king
moves you will play H4 Checkmate so uh
very very tough for wasley here he
played King to f8 and now Fabby just
played Knight to F5 engine precise moves
exclusively from fabbi uh Queen to F6
and now Queen to C5 with check we have
King to G8 and here Fabby played Queen
to C7 and he was in this position un
move 25 that Wesley so resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh The Rook is hanging and if you if you
try to save The Rook let's say you play
Rook to E8 now comes Knight to D6 once
again going after the Rook if you move
the Rook then comes Rook to G1 and
that's uh that's it once you move the
bishop simply Rook captures and G7 ends
the game Queen captures now queen queen
captures Rook as the queen was defending
the rook and after you block now even
Knight to E8 and there's no move for
black there are a couple of maybe
attempts here like H6 you want to try
and get the Rook into the game but now a
rook lift going for Rook to F6 and if
you play Rook to H7 trying to block this
then even Rook to G B6 check becomes
possible if you go here then simply this
will win the black queen and if you go
here then Queen to F6 with check you
even trade Queens here Queen captures
Knight captures and how do you defend
against Checkmate uh you don't that's
the problem you could play something uh
okay you could play something like
Bishop to H6 and then give up The Rook
but that end game is Dead lost and if
you try something like uh what Rook G7
then just Rook captures on H6 with check
the king is stuck here the Knight covers
all the squares and after Rook H7 Rook
captures on H7 ends the game with
Checkmate so yeah a couple of more moves
could have been played but Wesley saw
after Queen to C7 that it was pointless
and Fabby wins a very nice game deals
Wesley his first loss of the tournament
and Fabby is now uh in the lead and also
for those of you uh who are interested
here are the uh current live ratings
with this win Fabby rejoins his rightful
place as the member of the 2800 club uh
now only him and the highest rated
player in the world Magnus Carlson are
rated over 2800 and uh how does this
affect the the standings for the FED
candidates tournament for those of you
who still do not know only two more
spots are available one will be um
attributed to the highest rated player
as of January 20124 and the other one
will be the winner of the of the FED
circuit and uh okay Fabby is sort of
leading on both of those fronts but he
already qualified for the F candidates
tournament Magnus does not want to play
Hikaru qualified the ding is the
Champion so he will not be playing nepo
qualified and now wesle so and lener
Dominguez Perez are the top two
contenders um Wesley as he's leading the
the fiday circuit so he will probably
qualify via that and lener Dominguez
Perez will be leading via highest rating
as of January 2024 but okay that's still
a long way to go uh so we we'll see what
happens and also lener still has to play
one more tournament in order to qualify
because he does not have enough games in
2023 to actually qualify for the cand
this tournament so he will have to play
one more event and play it immaculately
to qualify but you have to be able to do
that if you are to stand the chance in
the candidates tournament uh so yeah
that's the game brilliant brilliant
miniature by Fab you can see how even in
the main line of the nimso the the Ponto
E3 line and even with Wesley sort of
surprising fabbi uh with this Ponto B6
novelty uh Fabby just you know every
move is an engine move and he just
completely obliterates Wesley off the
board I mean that's uh that's uh Faby
when he's when he's being himself and
when when he's not having a bad day uh
so yeah like I also mentioned on Twitter
uh during his world CH championship
match against Magnus in 2018 Fabby
almost overtook Magnus as the highest
rated player in the world because they
played 12 classical games and then every
game was a draw and with every draw
Fabby gained rating and Magnus lost
rating as Magnus was the highest rated
player and Fabby almost overtook him uh
but it as he he was very close to losing
one game but Magnus was was able to draw
it and he remained the highest rated
player in the world but yeah he he came
this close and now he he rejoins 2800
we'll see if he can uh get back to try
and take that uh number one spot away
from Magnus Carlson uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to to seag Ghost and I would like to
thank David gasparian Karim kawash
Muhammad Solan and David Anthony for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching Ing and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and also today at 9:00 p.m. Central
European Time I will be publishing a
game I played of Rapid chess uh as I'm
completely sleep deprived today I'm
awake since 3:00 a.m. in the morning and
uh you will see how that can affect your
chess uh in the weirdest way possible uh
see you
soon